talk about mayor laurie lightfoot only
giving interviews to non-white
journalists
ooh did you see this yeah i saw this
that's fire but it wasn't like
what did she say there was like a two uh
thing minimum or something like that
yeah it was basically like one-on-one
interviews
yeah specifically in like this period of
time she's only doing white and there
was only
two there was only two issues gonna give
out yeah like the headline is
far crazier yeah than what the actual
story was but it's the perfect headline
to get like especially conservative uh
twitter and conservative youtube
absolutely furious because it's
preposterous what she's saying she's
only giving out interviews for people of
color
it's the exact fear of all like these
white people who are going they're
taking away our lifestyle they're taking
away our culture
it's illegal to be white in america what
the [ __ ] is going on here but what is
the
the whole context were the interviews
about a specific topic that had to do
with people color
not necessarily so like something like
crying
i mean just look at the numbers you know
no but it's basically like looking at
her two-year mayoral anniversaries
coming up and so
some people are just like oh she's like
kind of politicking because these
one-on-one interviews that she's about
to do with these people
she wants them to be generally positive
and so if she's able to
get people interviews based off of like
some sort of special privilege they
might be uh
they might be more lenient with her so
she's not even doing this to be woke
she's doing it to protect herself
there's one thing that i caught in the
article mark linked which was
made it seemed like performative
wokeness because they interviewed that
post said they interviewed journalists
of multiple
races and they said uh other journalists
are gonna let him read his notes that he
don't get made fun of him
[Laughter]
this isn't fair how come i get made fun
of it i'm not that's done
and that's actually fair they're
silencing white man
the only people of color could have
notes okay
only comedians of color all right i just
got fully cut
bro first episode they don't cuck me
dude she's a [ __ ] bro comedian of color
you guys that's true i'm a [ __ ] right
i'm a little [ __ ] okay i'm a little cool
i'm a little [ __ ]
okay they said jonas of color who spoke
to the post said that when they tried to
question lightfoot on her administration
on issues like
police violence public schools and
housing they've been met back with
silence or dismissal
so when we want to ask you about some
real [ __ ] that affects the communities
of color
you don't give us anything you push back
you silence you dismiss us
and now you're doing this gesture of oh
i'm only letting journalists of color
interview me
it seems like performative openness it's
definitely performance she could have
just done it and i said nothing
true that's what's weird it's like like
most people yeah that's
why people do that's why they get [ __ ]
done yeah so i think the story broke
because i think a white chick hit her up
and was like yo can we do an interview
and she said
her office was like sorry we're only
doing interviews with she's like nah
you're black
no you're not black yeah and then i
think she's dumb thing
she broke the story i think yeah i mean
i understand like
it's smart if she wants to protect
herself she's like nah black person's
not gonna throw me under the bus
especially if i'm doing this
performative thing yeah like you know on
the strength like
candace owens need to pull up candace
that would be 100 because what you're
going to say then it's going to expose
what it really is
right which is i just want you to give
me softball questions in this interview
so i look good
which i understand from politicians
why we acting like politics ain't
exactly that it's performative measures
like everyone's
[ __ ] they just normally mask it
better because like trump was one of the
first ones i was like yo i'm only doing
interviews with people at [ __ ]
yeah people killed them for because
they're like yo like pretend but he was
saying that but then the most lit ones
were the ones where he was just in front
of
the wolves and they were coming after
him and he was clapping back right
like the worst thing he did is not let
them clap at him because that was
entertainers and that should be so
fireball he would always win somehow oh
yeah
just shut him down it's over that's a
dope thing about interviews you could be
like i'm out
yeah and like it's not like they could
be like well what do you have to do is
like well [ __ ] my president why am i
even talking to y'all
like i gotta practice yeah i guess
politicians are all performative but i
hate
seeing the politician in you like then i
know you're like when i see how full
[ __ ] you are i'm off board yeah
you gotta at least try to convince me
barack is a politician but then
[ __ ] comes across like a human
being
that's the art [ __ ] nailing through
that open gym and walking off
didn't you like that about trump that he
was so not a politician
yeah because it didn't seem like the
fraudulent this guy is so like
openly petulant and all that other [ __ ]
like fights everybody don't give a [ __ ]
at least that's a
i'm not conned by that i don't see an
act i see a person being
himself this [ __ ] seems like she's
acting i'm out barack didn't seem like
he was acting a very different way than
trump
but i like that yeah but you guys just
said politically the way to do it is
just by doing this without saying it
that would have been the political
things dude right now she's being like
yo i'm only speaking to black people
that's more real but again if i didn't
see that little note that i read off
straight off my phone and it was
completely okay that i did it
i wouldn't feel that way like all right
whatever any of you i take questions
from indians all day you know i mean
don't ask me about the farmers i'd be
forgetting sometimes
everything else bet let's go i don't
like this like oh hey
i'm only interviewing black people but
then when they ask you about real issues
uh
i'm not talking to you about that that
[ __ ] bothers me that bothers me
i see what he's saying he's like yo you
can ride for your people but if you
really arrive here with people you're
going to answer those questions about it
yeah yeah uh that's what one of the
journalists said he's like don't give us
little like interviews like actually
implement policy to help us bang and do
something i hate performative openness
yeah yeah a little lori lightfoot yeah
doesn't that sound like a nickname from
around the way
you know what i mean yo i got some fire
head yesterday from who
little lori lightfoot
[Laughter]
little lori lightfoot toed over here
bless the kid is it crazy to talk about
someone like that no
i mean we talk about people like that
we're not saying it's her yeah we're
saying the hypothetical person that's
it's not really lori lightfoot no it's a
hypothetical lori lightfoot
it's a native american young little
neighborhood native american
baby fat yeah bro that's worse
but she was a fast young girl why can't
you hook up a native americans
[Music]
what just happened huh no i was just i
thought it would be [ __ ] up but not
yeah they got names like that lightfoot
but i don't think we're allowed to call
them by those names
i mean they made up their name bro but i
thought only people from their tribe
came
who gives a [ __ ] yeah i hate when we do
this [ __ ] like we didn't already kill
him like
what is this other [ __ ] we're doing
extra changes
[Laughter]
whoever killed him